if you get shot
you convert to the other team until
there's only one team left standing
hello and welcome back to the x shot
versus nerf series here on the corridor
crew channel that's right today
has once again sponsored this video and
said guys we want the best of nerf to go
against the best of x shots we're going
to do that here today in a force on
force assimilation battle meaning that
there's going to be two teams one team
is going to have the best of extra one
team is going to have the best of nerf
and if you get shot you convert to the
other team until there's only one team
left standing say you're on on x shot
and you get shot by a person on nerf
you're gonna have a hat on if you're on
the x-shot team you're gonna set your
blaster down you're gonna take your hat
off you're gonna pick up one of these
nerf ones over here and you're gonna go
spawn against the loading bay door nerf
without the hats over there x shot with
the hats up there sam and nico you'll be
the captains everyone's gonna pick
blasters i've chosen the swarm secret
for quick draw and increased mobility i
chose the unreleased x-shot turbo fire
because it has a 20 round dart capacity
and it has the slam fire mechanism which
allows you to rapid fire in quick pace
games i picked the turbo advance
i picked the turbo advance because it's
got this huge drum mag we'll also be
using other favorite x-shot blasters
including the regenerator and the excess
which is a dual cylinder 12 shot
revolver i have chosen the nerf artemis
because it has my name on it
i've picked the flip fury because it
does this
hi my name is clinton jones and i chose
this little nerf blaster because i own
it and i want to get good at it and i
chose the nerf helios because i can load
two red balls in the end to knowing my
meg is running out part of the dream of
using this gun is like shooting and
shooting shooting then you drop one
whole drum load the neck drum if you're
shooting that many darts you're having a
good time i'm never gonna run out of
ammo i'm just gonna shoot as many of
them i'll be down there ready
game on
[Music]
oh
smoked them they all gone
yeah dude that fire power
you guys got flakes yeah we did
we did extra destroyed we're gonna
switch spawn points
game one
here
[Applause]
i got
oh
gosh dang it gotcha jake
i'm
all right good luck with your camera we
got one left as long as we don't get
picked and we take out mikko ground
belongs
i
we got one x shot win we got one nerf
one and then we need to do a final round
got a gun there shoots
maybe ren just needs to lay down
suppressive fire so we can move into the
space you make a great point and i agree
i'm gonna stay here clint you run as
fast as you can into that corridor back
there yeah yeah and i'll go through the
camera room ready you go come right back
okay okay game one
[Applause]
i got
oh wait no no what happens now i don't
know
my commanding officer you have to get
back in the game
tell me wait is that a nerf gun yeah
no hat yeah
[Applause]
all these blasters taking everyone out i
may or may not have
helped back to four on four and i'm on
the opposite team
i gotta look at the hats i keep
forgetting to look at hats play one
everyone versus jake
i wish the movie was a little bit better
the actors got to see it nailed it
music track phenomenal yeah
it's me versus everyone can jake the
soul x shot player make a comeback
convert some people and make it an even
game against come on
good luck buddy is it me versus all of
you yeah man i haven't been shot yet
everyone you see
every downfall there's an opportunity
they think they're gonna win
actually predict their movements and put
my darts on targets
he's in the back
and he going back here
[Music]
[Applause]
gotta go
uh i only have five rounds left this
game has gone back and forth multiple
times it's three on five now
they're already running again
oh
i got two of them watch your left
[Music]
[Applause]
that was a good team effort because
everybody was on the same team at the
end of the day what a what a wholesome
game extra two verse six comeback
converted it all back over
that's it i hope you guys enjoyed
watching this video we had a ton of fun
making it be sure to check out our other
x-shot versus nerf video we did a couple
weeks ago and remember all the links to
all the blasters are in the description
below including this here turbo fire
which is previously unreleased thanks
for watching and consider subscribing